[music playing] (SINGING)
[non-english speech]
ANNA COREN: An Iranian love
song plays from a cassette,
as a driver navigates his way
through the snow-dusted Lehman
Valley in northwestern
Afghanistan.
Crammed in the back
of his station wagon
is a mother and
her six children,
who've just left behind a
life of constant struggle
and hardship, all
they've ever known.
Among them,
nine-year-old Parwana.
Our cameraman, Siddiqui,
asks her how she's feeling.
I'm so happy, she says,
with a beaming smile.
CNN met Parwana,
dressed in pink,
in an internally
displaced camp in Bagdi's
province back in October.
Her father claims
he was selling her
to feed the rest of the family.
As a humanitarian crisis
grips the country,
he'd already sold his
12-year-old into marriage,
and told CNN that unless
his situation improved,
he would have to sell his four
remaining daughters as well,
including the
youngest, just two.
"If I didn't have these
daughters to sell,"
he asks, "what should I do?"
Parwana's buyer, who
lived in a nearby village,
confirmed he was taking the
9-year-old as his second wife.
INTERPRETER: I'm 55 years old.
I have a wife with four
daughters and a son.
I bought her for myself.
I will wait until
she becomes older.
ANNA COREN: CNN was
granted rare access to film
the final payment and handover.
The buyer asked for
it to take place
at a house in his
village, and not the camp,
for security reasons.
He paid a total of
200,000 Afghanis,
just over $2000 for Parwana,
in land, sheep and cash.
This is your bride,
please take care of her.
Says Parwana's father.
Of course, I will take care
of her, replies the man.
[non-english speech]
ANNA COREN: As he drags
her away, she whimpers.
Moments later, she digs
her heels into the dirt,
refusing to go,
but it's hopeless.
CNN's story caused an outcry.
- And a distressing story
out of Afghanistan, showing--
ANNA COREN: The network was
inundated with offers of help
from the public aid
organizations and NGOs
wanting to assist Parwana
and the other girls
featured in our story.
The US-based charity, Too
Young To Wed, took the lead.
Its founding executive
director, Stephanie Sinclair,
has been working to
end child marriage
and help vulnerable girls around
the world for almost 20 years.
She says the perfect storm
is brewing in Afghanistan,
and it's the girls
that are suffering.
STEPHANIE SINCLAIR: I know these
stories are difficult to watch,
and they're difficult
to do, and they
bring around a lot of concern.
But at the same time, we need
to keep people understanding
that this is happening.
We need to keep
ringing the alarm bell,
to understand these are
real girls and real lives,
and they can be changed.
ANNA COREN: Within
Bagdi's province,
there was widespread backlash
towards Parwana's father
and the buyer after our story
went to air, with claims they'd
brought shame on the community.
Even the Taliban told CNN
the practice is forbidden.
INTERPRETER: I request everyone
not to sell their children.
Child marriage is not a good
thing, and we condemn it.
ANNA COREN: Women's
rights activist,
and US citizen,
Mahbouba Seraj, who
chose to stay in Kabul after
the Taliban swept to power
in August to run
her women's shelter,
says Parwana's case is just
the tip of the iceberg.
MAHBOUBA SERAJ: It
is a lot of misery.
There is a lot of mistreatment.
There is a lot of abuse is
involved in these things.
And it will keep on
happening with the hunger,
with the winter, with poverty.
ANNA COREN: As a result
of the controversy
caused by the story, an
intervention from the charity,
Parwana was allowed to return
home after almost two weeks
with the buyer's family.
[non-english speech]
ANNA COREN: "Since
Parwana has been rescued,
I'm very happy for that,"
says Pawana's father.
He admitted to CNN that under
duress from the community
and some local media outlets.
He changed his story out
of embarrassment for what
he had done, and apologized.
The buyer is
unreachable for comment,
but the debt is
still outstanding.
Too Young to Wed then organized
to have Parwana, her mother,
and siblings removed
from the camp
with the father's permission.
The four-hour journey to
neighboring Herat province
was broken up with
some childhood fun
before arriving at the motel.
For children who've only
ever lived in a tent,
the novelty of being warm, fed
and safe wasn't wearing off.
[non-english speech]
ANNA COREN: "They rescued me.
They've given me a new
life," says Parwana.
"I thank the charity
for helping me."
A few days later, they
moved into the safe house.
Parwana's mother,
27-year-old Reza Gul,
has never lived in a house.
She was sold into
marriage at 13,
and has since had seven
children, six of whom
were girls.
Most days in the camp,
she would beg for food,
and often her family
would go to sleep hungry.
Now all she wants is to give
her children a better life.
[non-english speech]
"I have a dream, a
wish, to go to school
and start an
education," she says.
"I have a lot of
wishes for then."
Too Young to Wed
has already begun
distributing aid to Parwana's
impoverished camp among others.
While the small charity is
prepared to bridge the gap,
they're calling on the large
aid organizations to step up.
STEPHANIE SINCLAIR:
These are communities
that have relied on
international aid
for the last 20 years.
And so, with a lot
of that aid stopping,
these people didn't
stop needing support.
We can't let them pay the
price, because ultimately girls
always pay the biggest price.
ANNA COREN: I speak
to Parwana on Zoom,
through my colleague Bassir.
Hello Parwana, I'm Anna.
[non-english speech]
INTERPRETER: How are you?
How are you feeling?
ANNA COREN: I'm very
good, thank you.
How are you?
[non-english speech]
INTERPRETER: I'm fine.
I'm so happy.
I'm safe.
I rescued.
ANNA COREN: Then she asks, "When
are you sending me to school?"
She wants to study and
become a doctor or a teacher,
but fairy-tale endings are
few and far between for girls
in Afghanistan.
Even more so now than ever.
Anna Coren, CNN.